good morning welcome to this press
conference that is to present as you
know the proposal to end the seasonal
clock changes in Europe in 2019 giving
Member States the freedom to design once
and for all whether they want to
permanently apply summer or winter term
the purpose was already announced by the
president on Wednesday and I think vice
president Sepp which officially Bull's
to be here with us today to explain it
and to explain the sense and vice
president thank you thank you very much
Violeta ladies and gentlemen as I'm sure
you would remember as it starts the
European Commission promised to be
serious about the principle to be big on
big things and small and small thing and
we say that our actions mat must
withstand the scrutiny of
proportionality and subsidiarity and
this week's proposal on seasonal clock
changes shows that we stand by our words
and the message we are sending is very
clear the time has come not to meddle in
time and lets me highlight why firstly
we are reflecting what people are asking
for and I believe that today we are
speaking to every household in the
European Union approximately 4.6 million
replies to the public consultations
coming almost exclusively from
individuals is really an impressive
turnout 84% of replies were in favor of
abolishing that biannual clock changes
and this is the highest number ever
received in any public consultation
organized by the Commission
needless to say negative health impacts
were among the most prominent arguments
secondly the seasonal time changes seem
to be outdated and no longer
make sense the tradition of summertime
dates back to the first and second world
wars when it was a wartime measure to
save energy most of the European
countries introduced the summertime in
the 70s in the wake of the oil crisis
and have been applying it ever since but
newer studies confirmed that the energy
savings are nowadays marginal especially
under the project of the energy union we
are designing new strong policies and
tools to boost energy efficiency we
clearly are heading towards smart cities
smart buildings and smart solutions
which will bring up much more savings
than the changes of the clock and
thirdly we are reflecting what a growing
number of member states as well as the
European Parliament request especially
that the Member States will be free to
decide about the individual time regimes
summer or winter once for all but
importantly in a coordinated manner to
avoid negative repercussions on the
internal market before we all later walk
you through the proposal let me conclude
by underlying also with the view of the
next European Parliament elections that
process is not micromanaging people's
life for the sake of it and that we
listen and you respond to what people
have to say and before passing
floatability I really would like to
thank her because she was a driving
force behind starting these
consultations and been very enthusiastic
about this issue and I think therefore
we are also able to present you this
proposal in such a record time thank you
thank you thank you very much March and
let's now get into the steps that we
will be taking in the next couple of
months first of all let me be clear what
we are proposing we are proposing to put
an end to seasonal clock changes already
as of next year
this very ambitious timetable will allow
citizens to reap the benefits as soon as
possible second we are setting out a
clear and short timetable for the
changes to take place
third finally in order to maintain a
harmonized approach we are encouraging
consultations at national levels to
ensure a coordinated approach of all
member states so let me be clear
Commission has a competences to to
propose that we have a unified approach
to either we have time changes or we
don't have it is the subsidiarity issue
member states now have to decide either
they wanna stick with summer or winter
time so it would be worth to clarify yet
another question that sometimes is
causing some confusion and I need to be
very clear we are not proposing that the
whole EU switches to either summer or
winter time or we are proposing is that
we do it together at the same time so it
will be the choice of a member state to
decide in which time zone they want to
be so what's next
given the ambitious timeline I'm really
inviting all member states now to start
with the necessary preparations as soon
as possible I really hope that the
Parliament and the member states will be
able to keep up with this ambitious
schedule and that's why the work needs
to start immediately I already spoke
with the kerima Delhi the chair of Train
Committee and in the European Parliament
as well as with Minister offered from
the Austrian presidency so we can really
hit the ground running and
swiftly in this proposal and of course
nothing is sure yet so either the
council and the Parliament it's a KO
decision process we will have to engage
in a trial lock at the end and decide
together but if we can come up with this
vicious schedule the timeline is the
following after we received a green line
alight from the colleges laters
hopefully by the end of this year so I
would like to invite Parliament and the
council to take the position before they
this year ends there will be no more
seasonal clock changes as of the end of
October 2019 so in October 2009 teen
will be the last time when we will
change the clock but now let me hand the
word to you in case you have any
additional questions all the proposals
there is a press release Q&A with a link
also to the results of the detailed
result of the consultation of the
consequences of brexit is that the UK
will not be subject to the changes that
you're proposing and the effect of that
could mean that if the proposals are
agreed a new time border will emerge on
the island of Ireland between north and
south of Ireland for seven months of the
year
there's the Commission proposed to allow
member states an exemption from from
this rule or will you insist that the
British if they are trying to sign an
agreement with us about a single market
adhere to all the single market rules
and therefore also adopt this measure
we are doing this together but it's a
member-states decision which timezone
the clique I think I think I
misunderstood the proposal when it was
made my understanding is that the
timezone that member states am part of
is certainly a competence of the member
states but whether or not they sign up
to summer time the summer time change is
not is going to be a common decision and
everybody will will be required to
follow it now we're on I would like to
be really clear because this is an
excellent question it needs to be very
clearly communicated the Commission's
competence is that we decide together we
propose that we stop changing time this
is Commission's proposal competence and
we proposed it the decision on either
the country wants to use summer or
winter time its member state competence
very clearly maybe I can walk you
through just for clarification because
this will help you by April next year
member states need to send an official
notification to the Commission either
they want to keep summer or they want to
keep winter time so this is the
timeframe within which all these
consultations on the level of a member
states can take place so next year
October will be the last time if the co
legislature decide that Commissioner to
support the Commission's proposal will
be the last time that we will switch
clocks either we will stay with us
more time or those countries that decide
to go with the wintertime they will
switch it to winter time in October and
that will be it in late August
jean-claude juncker said on German TV
unless summertime is coming so everybody
understood that you would want to force
everyone to take summertime now you say
member states are gonna choose when did
it change and my second question is if
now on a country wants to stop changing
time no the country cannot change time
on itself because this is now EU
competence and when President euchre
referred to summertime this is the most
commonly used word for this time clock
changes so when he said we're gonna when
he said summer time he meant really the
process not the summer time per se so we
often say in our publication stood
before we used to say Oh summer time
arrangements but in fact this is really
the arrangements for switching the time
so it's just the way how we use this
theorem so it we are very clear and
since we started to communicate that it
was never ever communicated in any other
different way Commission has a
competences to say either we all switch
or nobody switches but if we decide to
stop switching then every member state
has to decide which time zone they wanna
be and which summer or winter time they
wanna use and as it was stressed there
is a call for coordination on some
member states which is also valuable for
UK
the radical Italian radio to question if
I made the first one is it's quite
political in February the European
Parliament which is an institution
formed by people elected by the people
voted against the if you remember the
amendments and so on against a proposal
such the one that you are doing now in
November and you said that European
Parliament there was a discussion at the
Transport Council and just one member
states was in favor of changing the
status quo so accept the fact that there
are a constituency in Germany and
Finland of people well organized that
has participated massively in your
consultation except a good interview by
president younger in a German TV what
what is the reason since in February you
said Commissioner boots that there was
no reason to change the status quo
the second question your proposal
potentially you asked for coordination
but potentially could could let Member
State to do whatever they want France in
the wintertime Italy in the summertime
Austrian wintertime do you think that
it's responsible to make such proposal
in in this way subsidiarity and so on
but at the end of the day if there is no
coordination and in this area I don't
think that coordination it's very
popular among member states in Europe do
you think that it will work thank you
thank you very much for this question as
well this is certainly not a decision
that happened overnight since I became a
commissioner in 2014
this is the most oftenly most frequent
topic that I've been called to the
European Parliament to discuss so it is
something that obviously is of a great
interest it is true that Parliament so
far has not really voted on dropping or
not dropping the summer and winter time
but in February the Parliament gave me
yet another time to take a close look at
this issue and with a resolution that
they voted for not against for so that's
why we decided to do public consultation
and it's true I received over 13
citizens citizens papers research that
is an enormous number of research has
been done on the effects of summertime
it is fair to say that they are very
balanced there are lots of arguments why
to keep the changes and lots of
arguments why not to keep the changes
but let's remind ourselves why we
Europeans decided to start changing the
time it was in the first world war to
save Coyle
for the purpose of the war it was in the
Second World War for to save Coyle for
the purpose of the war and to get energy
that was necessary for military
activities and it was in the 70s when we
had a cries all crisis so all these
reasons are no longer on the table and
when citizens ask us all the time to act
and remove the obstacles in the system
that are no longer needed we could not
really find a justifiable reasons to
keep the time based on why we made this
decision for and president shifter which
already mentioned we are doing so many
efforts now in saving the energy
consumption in improving the efficiency
of our system improving the efficiency
of our devices that this just doesn't
make sense anymore but
you can always argue that a longer
morning hour it's good for something or
the longer afternoon hour is good for
something after the consultation
consultation gave us just the last push
and the president was very clear we are
not asking citizens of Europe to submit
their opinion to ignore them so there
was no good reasons in all the research
papers there is a good reason because
there is no no conditions that prompted
the change of time today present and the
public consultation was very clear the
citizens want to change but let me
answer the other question when you said
that member states are not really good
in coordination we have a Co legislation
Parliament will discuss that people will
have a direct input through the MEP s--
to express their opinion one more time
we have a council and member states they
will discuss that it was indicated by
the Minister of Austria yesterday that
this could be one of the topics on our
informal console so member states will
consult each other they will discuss
this topic and of course what I'm
inviting everyone is that we come up
with the proposals from the Parliament
and the council by the end of the year
that we see what is really the condition
in the Member States what is really the
opinion in the Member States and if
there will be a prevailing opinion that
we should keep the time change of course
it's a co legislation we're not going to
be push we're not gonna be able to push
through without a cooperation with the
Parliament and the council but as I said
based on the fact that the reasons don't
exist anymore based on the facts that
people with the overwhelming
participation which is ten times bigger
than ever before this prompted a
proposal that you have today on the
table from the Commission
my Finnish News Agency could you give us
an overview how many member states are
in favor of this proposal and have some
member states already made the decision
whether they will choose wintertime or
summertime thank you / member states you
have in all your materials I don't have
per se for every member state now but we
got participation from all member states
some member states were more active than
the others but I can tell you already
that Portugal Cyprus Poland they had
like the largest amount of participants
that voted for summertime
these are 79% 73% 72% for the summer
time and we had for example in Finland
Denmark and Netherlands more people to
go with winter time that I have because
these are the big numbers but in the
materials you can see the detail the
composition of all
have government's made decisions already
and so travailing in s22 before this
proposal some of the member states
already submitted their opinion I don't
want to point them out because as I said
the consequence the council
consultations will still be ongoing so
but yeah we do have first positive
responses from member states
yes Stephanie said
santé aren't you afraid that you
actually create more problems than that
you satisfy maybe citizens first and
secondly I'm a bit surprised at you that
you put so much emphasis on this
consultation with because I mean as we
know the huge part of the answers came
from very few countries and a lot of
other countries participation was
minimal and then last on which basis
actually you could prevent Ireland for
example as my colleague asked to
continue with time switch because I mean
you're giving up competence in a way so
why should I don't be able to continue
thank you
yes it will be switched on no just to
complement the arguments of my colleague
I still remember very well that when I
was going through the hearing on
becoming the Transport Commissioner for
this commission the first question I
received was about the summer time and I
know that already at that time we had
quite thick file on the discussion on
the some time and then the changes of
our system so this is a question which
is with us which is pertinent already I
would say for for more than 10 years and
I think that with all these results you
received through the different studies
and impact assessment the different
submissions we received from citizens
and scientific community it was quite
clear that the originally purpose of the
clock changes which was saving that the
energy is not there anymore
and then that discomfort of our citizen
was what was growing and therefore I
think we saw such a big turnout in this
consultation which we simply couldn't
disregard because as you heard they
already several times this was because
they were participation and and the
preference was like crystal clear
eighty-four percent of people taking
part in these consultations been clearly
for abolishing abolishing the time at
the same time I also have faith in our
member states in the European Parliament
that we will do it in a smart way in a
coordinated way that the neighboring
countries
Flanders balunia here in Belgium that of
course they would call Rene they would
talk to each other
and that we will find the solution which
is the best for our citizen and best for
our economies and here of course I can
also assure you that Commission will do
our best to make sure that we will
proceed in in a smart way because why
the summer time and clock changes stayed
with the Commission why is it
the responsibility of the Transport
Commissioner because there is very
important element here and this is that
we have to be absolutely clear how we
are setting the conditions for Airlines
for trains for every single human
activity which is very much depending on
precise time measuring and precise times
execution and therefore it really
affects I would say every aspect of
economy in our daily life and therefore
we have to have absolute clarity how we
do this in the European Union therefore
it's the video European Commission
therefore we want to do our utmost it
would avoid any possible complication
and I have lots of faith that together
with the Member States and European
Parliament defined such a solution at
the same time they also respond to the
the preoccupations worries and concerns
of our citizens because one of the most
quoted the reason why people prefer to
get rid of this clock change was the
health issues different discomforts and
I think that if today we can clearly say
that the original purpose of this is
gone that we have better smarter
solutions how to save energy so I think
that they are just doing writing
proposing this new way forward and I
just like to add it is not only because
the citizen spoke but citizen gave a
full indication that this matters to
them the reason is as vice-president
structure which already pointed out is
that the reasons for energy savings are
no longer there oil war oil we are
looking now for alternative sources of
energy we are reshaping the way how our
technology is performing and the
research you could always find the
research that will support the clock
change and you will always find the
research that we will be against the
clock change so the other two reasons
prevailed
Telegraph Netherlands you say the choice
is up to the to the Member States of
course that's very you made it very
clear and you want to coordinate but
what if for me it's not clear what if
the Netherlands for example chooses
wintertime and Belgium summertime and
Germany summer time and Austria winter
time is that an acceptable outcome for
the European Commission or is the
project then killed and nothing changes
well already today we have three time
zones in EU so we know how to coexist
with three times on three time different
three times the point of either stop or
continue with the times which is that
it's predictable from that point on
so no more changes will be predictable
time arrangements from that point on no
more half a year changes we do of course
we will always respect opinion of a
Member State but I'm sure that the
council will make an effort to try to
encourage Member States to do it in the
most favorable way for the neighboring
arrangements actually what you are
saying is that it is possible that for
example Belgium has a different time
zone over time than the Netherlands that
is an acceptable outcome many in theory
many options are possible I do not want
to speculate what the member states will
really decide but theoretically yes why
the hurry
does it have something to do with the
European elections maybe no it doesn't
have to do with the European elections
as vice president already mentioned this
is a topic that been around for a very
long time and after the February when
the Parliament was very clear in the
resolution that they are calling upon
the Commission one more time to take a
close look at this
a subject we were doing it as quick as
we could to respond and that's the
nature of their procedures maybe I can
add one more argument because now we are
indeed in a hurry on some other files as
well we just spent the part of this week
in Strasbourg and we had a lot of
meetings with the members of the
European Parliament we are talking to
presidency because we just want to make
sure that all that proposals into which
we invested enormous amount of energy
will not just simply stay on the table
and we really want to wrap them up
really want to start the next decade in
my case and really the new rules for
smart use of energy we evolved to have
all the measures which would help us do
that climate change in place you want to
make sure that we are going to modernize
our car industry we want to make sure
that our people would live in a smart
houses and therefore I think that delay
here is simply not acceptable and I am
sure that it would understand that for
us it's a prime objective to really
conclude our work and to show also in
the European Parliament election so this
is what the commission was working on
this is what we proposed to the European
citizens as a results and are built on
how we how we did over the last years
and therefore you will see us now very
often in the parliament talking to the
presidency to the Member States to make
sure that the proposals which are
pending which are on on table will
actually be completed I think it's very
very important in many files upon which
you are working together with viola tan
will be very very active because I think
we cannot miss this opportunity and and
lose the time so we would not or we
would prevent our citizens to benefit
from all that modernization changes we
we put on the table so that that's the
hurry and I'm sure that we will hear
from ourselves and from our colleagues
that will be very very active with the
colleges later to make sure that
would really use every single day to
make sure that we will complete our work
it's Martin with the Danish newspaper
called you'll ins person can ask about
the public hearing did you do anything
to verify these four million answers or
is there actually a risk that the
hearing might have been hijacked by
robots or internet trolls and another
question for decades computer systems
and other electronic devices have been
built and programmed to you know to
change the clocks and now all of this
have to be reprogrammed all over Europe
so do you have any estimation about the
costs of this to to companies and
citizens now at this point what I can
say is that the benefits also economical
benefits from changing not to stop
changing the time are big enough that
they justify these last adjustments
which will never will never be needed in
the future again and in transport that
is quite an issue imagine in logistic
networks every half a year you either
lose or gain one hour and to ensure the
smooth operation a predictable operation
that is not disturbed every six months
these are also economical benefits
behind it I mean it's almost it's a joke
but it's also true that also cows hard
it's hard for them to understand that
they need to be milked one hour earlier
or later because for them every day and
the time clock is the same so there are
lots of small effects that at the end
they they end up and as I said this has
been written so much about this in the
last 10 20 years since the 70s when it
was the
last time when we really got engaged and
that is also the reason why we took on
board all the arguments I've been as I
said consulted and challenged by the
Parliament in the last four years four
times in the Parliament and this was the
last element to the whole puzzle was
this public consultation and it's not
the only source and the only reason why
we're deciding to avoid it why we
decided to put this as a proposal
forward for
did you verify any of the four million
answers all the answers were actually
handled also by hand because there were
comments there was a commentary window
in the in the questionnaire II and more
details about how it was verified you
could get from my technical team right
after this and this meeting and there
was also capture method to avoid the
automatic engine it works Kalavati team
Chronos III just two questions if I may
the first one is that I mean northern
countries are more likely to choose
winter time for all the year and
southern countries are more likely to
choose daylight saving time for all the
year and you said that in Europe there
are three time zones but there are
longitudinally distributed this
introduces a a latitude factor which is
I mean might complicate things and
member states might find difficult to
find an agreement on this it has this
been factored in in your choice I'd and
the second one is just a detail you said
that in October to 2019 would be would
be the last time there would be clock
change this is just for countries which
are gonna choose the winter time for all
the year and and Indiana will stay the
same in daylight's I mean is that
correct correct thank you
the first question it's correct the last
statement and the first statement is as
I said we will have now in deaf
consultations with member states will
conduct in-depth consultations and of
course in the council this debate will
be also discussed I'm sure that we will
get at the end a good solution but I'm
not going to speculate what is going to
be in the counseling okay let's start
I mean to cover just issues that weren't
touched because we don't have so much
time patron please
you
hello peter fonda the Slovenian News
Agency I have a question about the
financial aspect of this proposal
do you have an assessment how much this
will cost and who will pay for it I mean
you already touched upon the economic
benefits and if you could maybe
elaborate a little bit on this thank you
I would really ask you to talk to my
team after that about all the
simulations and information that are
related to our decision but let me be
again very clear what commission
proposed was that we stopped changing
time and the rest will follow in Akko
decision with the parliament and council
and allow me just a little comment that
usually I'm very much attacked that
they're being too slow in reacting this
time I feel like we've been too fast so
but still I think we as always through
the cosy decision process we will get
the best solution for Europeans yes so I
have two questions the first one on the
article qu the proposal you said if a
Member States decides to change it
standard time or times in hhv so it can
do that
every six but not every six months but
with a notification of six months so if
Member States decides twice you that it
wants to just change the standard time
doesn't mean that de facto is kind of
pry the club change so that was first
question and the second question given
the fact that like on transport so many
topics today
so first mobility package second
mobility pocket third mobility package
aviation passengers rights for trains so
do you
find it relevant to add another issue
and given the file it's really
complicated to get jails on that thank
you very much I don't think that Davis
savings summer winter time affects their
mobility package 1 2 & 3
and yeah with all respect we have a lot
of tactical options we can theorize
about a lot of different options that
are on the table but in practical terms
I do count on rationality of member
states that they will make the best
decision and we will accept that of
course that we can discuss the details
but once the notification April 2010 is
made that's it
counter stage either in summer time or
in winter time there is no way of doing
further notifications now you mentioned
some financial benefits in aviation but
you know aviation flight planning is
then under the provisions of the Chicago
Convention for International Civil
Aviation and that includes that flight
planning is that under Zulu time which
is Cremeans mean time which is subject
to UK regulations of the diagonal time
same is going to still apply in a V
Asian what is the what's the real let's
say financial application in aviation
and in the case we have also time zones
north and south that's going to
complicate things even more did you
consider this and in the overall
estimation agree with the proportional
things
well I don't want to go into details but
even today some member states are
considering to actually readjust even
further with the neighboring countries
the time the time zones because they
decided in the past for whatever reason
to to pick one over the other as far as
the businesses we already have made
these implications about our potential
proposal before we are also inviting now
all businesses to readjust accordingly I
think in the past businesses have done
it many times as we know that in the
past with some countries didn't have the
daylight saving times others had in 80's
when this joint approach to changing the
time was established these three
adjustment had to be done again as you
know turkey already decided not to have
the changes in summer time so the
businesses had to adjust an aviation as
well China doesn't have that anymore
and many a Russia decided not to have it
there are many countries that already
already sent these messages to the
global community and the global
community had to readjust aviation had
to readjust so yes businesses are aware
of that they know how to do it and I'm
sure that they will be able to readjust
one last more time okay I would say that
this press conference showed that there
is not only a big interest from citizens
bouncing from the media on this issue
and I